I am alternating at a fungal meds that had been sent home with me from the hospital to address
a fungal cough, so a fungal infection in her lungs. Plus using cortiseps, remember I said how
cortiseps mushroom was so so good for your lungs. Alternating olive leaf, which is good for fungus,
I stated a difficult can and noxophyll. I wonder if you're able to prescribe at all looking to get
a sporadox prescription. No, I apologize, and I cannot subscribe, so looking for a functional
medical medicine doctor would be best. There are some naturally-minded critics in Minnesota. I know
this person is a Minnesota that I'd recommend, so I can email that to you from Minnesota patients.
I have access to supplements, one with beta-glucan. Beta-glucan is from mushrooms, you get it from
other sources too, but it's polysaccharide. It stimulates your immune system. Actually the cortiseps
has beta-glucan in it as well. One with amino acids to help stop muscle loss. Should I be adding these to
what I'm taking? Certainly can. I don't have this person's protocol in front of me. Pretty sure I
have other beta-glucans, but they're sheltered. My beta-glucan is probably my favorite supplement at
all times, so that's why I love mushrooms so much.